the Happy Valley in the Hong Kong jockey
club it's kind of a mecca for horse
racing people they're betting more in
terms of their income than almost
anywhere else on the planet in 2001 with
very large jackpot had built up roughly
20 million dollars u.s. 1 million people
placed a wager on the triple trio for
that race that's equivalent to about one
in seven of the population of Hong Kong
at the time last leg at the triple 3 and
away they go are the triple trio is
three races the top three finishers in
any order in all three races the odd was
something like 10 million to one
mascot spotting back that Bobo in front
of Miss the training double for Derek
crew no one came forward to claim the
prize but the winner was an American
professional gambler at that point he
was making so much money from his
gambling activities that it didn't
matter to him this is the story of a
Shou a computer nerd who came up with a
system to beat horse racing and made a
billion dollars
my name's KITT shall L I'm a reporter
for Bloomberg and a writer for Business
Week fundamental unfairness of sports
betting is that over a period of time
you will almost always lose if you make
a lot of bets gambling sports betting is
slanted against you as a punter as a
gambler bill benta decided to beat that
system he just became captivated this
idea that these games which supposedly
casinos have his longfang advantage you
could actually beat with the right
methods I'm adding for Chomsky I'm a
mathematician and science Weitzman
when he was younger he saw signs lanta
city that said card counters are banned
from our games and for him that sign
Lacey said card counting must work he
picked up a book by Ed Thorpe could beat
the dealer which outlined the
fundamentals of card counting you're
looking for how many high or low cards
have emerged and how many might remain
in the pack if you think there's a high
chance that there are lots of high cards
left in the pack that changes the odds
in your favor lots of people went and
tried card counting build was more
successful than most manage to
make some money and make it we're out of
it he teamed up with Alan Woods
Australian professional gambler but as
is always the problem with professional
gamblers casinos don't like people who
win and they were systematically
excluded from all the major casinos
around Vegas so there needs to find a
new game
Alan Woods was interested in horse
racing and between them they talked
about it and became attracted to the
betting scene in Asia and in particular
the Hong Kong jockey club where they
were aware there was this huge horse
racing market they might be able to tap
into one of the reasons that Hong Kong
has a big advantage if you're trying to
use mathematical and statistical methods
is it's almost like a laboratory for
studying horse racing in Hong Kong
you've got to race horses that dominates
you've got accusing my betting activity
you've got a pool about a thousand
horses you've got hundreds of races of
the year so if you're designing
something that's going to generate
reasonably consistent data to study
these patterns hong kong is a place that
you want to go so they sent allan woods
to hong kong and he came back with with
all the results of racing in hong kong
going back five ten years I think and
they manually fed that into a very basic
early computer to try and create a
statistical model they fed the numbers
into their computer it took them a long
time taking about nine months so what
they would do is use these these
measures of horses quality and come up
with a prediction of each horses in a
given race their chances of winning and
then they would compare that to what the
odds on the board
implied those horses chance of winning
and what you want is a horse where the
odds imply it has a very low chance but
your model says it has a pretty decent
chance in the course of researching a
story I spoke to gambling experts they
said it was impossible couldn't be done
if you bet long enough on horses you
will lose money there are lots of
factors that go into a horse winning or
not the favorite doesn't always win and
his first year of betting I think he
lost one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars they had all sorts of glitches
because their data wasn't perfect the
fact that the jockey club takes a
fifteen seventeen percent cut makes it
harder to be sustainably profitable it
means you have to be not just better
than the market but you need to be about
twenty percent better than the mark
to stop making a profit in a pari-mutuel
system in this case the Hong Kong jockey
club that the odds are determined by the
action so the number of people betting
on each particular horse and the sums
they bet Turman the odds and what they
did alongside developing predictions was
find ways of really carefully trickling
their money into the market if there's a
certain amount in the pot and you go and
put a huge amount on a particular horse
you're actually going to affect how much
money you can make back because you're
gonna swing the market so much towards a
particular horse eventually he came to
incorporate the public odds into his
model and that was a huge breakthrough
for him he'd worked out that the
individual decisions of a million
punters in Hong Kong
were actually a fairly accurate
predictor of of a horse's chance of
success bill bent has been betting for a
few years in the Hong Kong and he's
starting to make serious money enough
that he can hire employees to place bets
over the phone hall for him he buys a
lot of computers he hires a nice office
it was really operating like a business
and much like you'd see the sort of
actions in a modern hedge fund in that
they were accumulating really good data
they were analyzing that data and then
they were developing predictions that
they could act on and really the nature
of this business for syndicate it wasn't
that they were placing your bet and then
celebrating it was just as almost a
systematic trading role where they were
expecting to make money over time
one day he gets contacted by the Hong
Kong jockey club and as a professional
gambler who's worked in Vegas I think he
assumed it was going to be bad news they
might try and kick him off the betting
pool and instead they said you're one of
our best customers what can we do to
make your life better because they take
a percentage of the total betting pool
the more computer betters there are and
the more money they're betting the more
profit they make bill wanted a computer
and they gave him one they gave him
something called the customer input
terminal and allowed him to stop having
to have employees pick up the phone it's
been 10 20 seconds each time placing a
bet he could do it in a fraction of a
second so allowed him to make more bets
the more bets you make the more likely
it is that your edge pays off so when he
was suddenly able to make thousands upon
thousands of bets that the click of a
button it dramatically increased his
profitability there grew this kind of
sub industry of specialists I don't
think the Hong Kong betting public had
broad awareness that there were computer
experts using statistical modeling to
bet in the same pools that they were
they simply weren't well-known they
never appeared in the press no one knew
the name bill benter the amount of money
that was coming out of the pool and
going to computer teams just grew and
grew and grew and grew the computer
betting teams got too good they were
making too much money they were making
so much money the jockey club saw what
was happening and they realized that if
word got out that the specialist
computer teams foreign owned and run
were siphoning money out of the betting
pool to the detriment of the average
bettor it might discourage people from
from going to the racetrack and making
bets they abruptly cut off bill bento
but then this record jackpot came along
I think they made fifty thousand bets
they spent well over a million Hong Kong
dollars they went into it deciding that
even if they won they weren't gonna
claim the money I almost did it to test
how good their model was by this point
so they come up with the home bin some
zero and face trying to make all mascot
reject goes to him now das bill Ben to
fit into the stereotype of professional
gamblers no hardly at all and kicked a
length clear he had more than thirty
winning combinations but he had one
single winning tickets that correctly
predicted all nine placed finishes and
that was the one that had a big payout
there's a purity about what he did you
know he was faced with a technical
numerical challenge his job is to beat
the odds in horse racing and the way he
did it was applying science this problem
in a way that most gambling people don't
he's still working away at that problem
you know it's a the algorithm is is
constantly evolving and changing and
improving and Bill was really one of the
first people to apply computing power
and technology to a system of odds
making but that practice is now spread
all over the world not just by betters
but by bookmakers too so in a sense he
deke he transformed the industry his
obsession is the science of gambling and
probability and to this day it's what he
does
[Music]
you
you